(HOST) IRA GLASS: From WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. And friends, let's begin. Open your bibles, please, to the Book of Exodus , chapter 32. God has just brought the Israelites out of Egypt. He's heard their prayers. They are not slaves anymore. They are in the desert. Moses is now up on Mt. Sinai, where God is giving him the ten commandments, and it is taking a while.
来自芝加哥WBEZ电台和国际公共广播电台，这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。朋友们，让我们开始吧。请翻开你们的圣经，找到《出埃及记》第32章。上帝刚刚把以色列人从埃及救出来，他听到了他们的祈祷。他们不再是奴隶了，他们正身处沙漠。摩西现在在西奈山上，上帝正在那里传授给他十诫，这需要一些时间。
And although evidence of God's existence couldn't have been clearer just days and weeks before-- he split the Red Sea for them, and they marched across. He drowned Pharaoh's army for them. He punished the Egyptians with boils and locusts and frogs. Even though God had done all that, now they're in the desert, Moses is gone, and it's been a while. And in a certain way, in this moment, the Israelites are just like us, hapless idiots wandering around, wondering what their future will be, where their God is, if God even cares.
尽管仅仅在几天或几周前，上帝存在的证据已经再清楚不过了——他为他们分开了红海，让他们走过去。他为他们淹没了法老的军队。他用脓疮、蝗虫和青蛙惩罚了埃及人。尽管上帝做了这一切，但现在他们身处沙漠，摩西离开了，已经过去了一段时间。从某种程度上说，在这一刻，以色列人就像我们一样，是四处游荡的倒霉白痴，想知道他们的未来会怎样，他们的上帝在哪里，上帝是否还在关心他们。
So they go to Moses's brother, Aaron, and ask him to make some gods. He collects some gold, makes the golden calf. God learns about it, and he is not happy. Biblical scholar Pauline Viviano picks up the story from there. God is going to kill everyone.
于是他们去找摩西的兄弟亚伦，要求他制造一些神像。亚伦收集了一些黄金，铸造了一只金牛犊。上帝得知此事，非常不高兴。圣经学者宝琳·维维亚诺从这里继续讲述这个故事。上帝打算杀光所有人。
(SUBJECT) PAULINE VIVIANO: He tells Moses that he's going to wipe them out, and Moses intercedes. It's one of the greatest dialogs of the Bible because Moses pretty much convinces God not to destroy the people because if he does so, he'll ruin his reputation as a God. People will say this Yahweh God, he just brings people out in the desert to destroy them. So that if he wants to maintain his reputation, he better not wipe them out.
他说他要将他们彻底消灭，摩西为此代求。这是《圣经》中最伟大的对话之一，因为摩西几乎说服了上帝不要毁灭这些人，因为如果他那样做，他作为上帝的声誉就会毁于一旦。人们会说，这个耶和华上帝只是把人带到沙漠里去毁灭他们。所以，如果他想维护自己的声誉，最好不要把他们赶尽杀绝。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: God apparently decides that he wants to protect his reputation. Or of course, being God, he has reasons for the whole thing that we will never understand. Whatever, in any case, God has mercy. Only 3,000 people are killed. The golden calf is destroyed. And this turns out to be a lesson that happens again and again in the Bible.
上帝显然决定要维护自己的声誉。或者当然，作为上帝，他有我们永远无法理解的理由。无论如何，上帝最终还是仁慈了。只有3000人被杀。金牛犊被毁。事实证明，这在《圣经》中是一个反复出现的教训。
(SUBJECT) PAULINE VIVIANO: It's made over and over and over and over again throughout the biblical text. As soon as you get into the historical books of the Bible, the pervasive or the continuous sin of the people is that they worship other gods. And so constantly, every catastrophe is understood in terms of Yahweh punishing his people for their failure to worship him alone.
在《圣经》文本中，这一点被反复提及。一旦你进入《圣经》的历史书，就会发现人们普遍存在或持续不断的罪恶就是崇拜其他神灵。因此，每一场灾难都被理解为耶和华因他们没有专一敬拜他而进行的惩罚。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: The idea that you would have a God who does not want you to worship other gods, which seems completely normal to us, as best as anybody can tell, at the time of the Bible, that is a brand new idea. The people in that part of the world at that time mostly seemed to worship lots of gods, gods who did not care who else you worshipped. And it turns out that it is not an accident that it's a golden calf in this story that's being worshipped in this key moment in the desert. Here's professor John Spencer, who wrote the passage on the golden calf in the Anchor Dictonary of Theology.
上帝不希望你崇拜其他神灵，这在我们看来完全正常。据目前所知，在《圣经》时代，这是一个全新的概念。当时那个地区的人们大多崇拜许多神，而这些神并不关心你还崇拜谁。事实证明，在这个关键时刻，沙漠中崇拜的是一只金牛犊并非偶然。这里有约翰·斯宾塞教授，他为《锚定神学词典》撰写了关于金牛犊的文章。
(SUBJECT) JOHN SPENCER: There were many traditions in the ancient Near East where people did indeed worship a calf or a golden calf or a bull. There sometimes were calves that were made out of bronze. There were sometimes calves that had either a silver or a gold alloy put over the outside of them. And probably the story was intended to set the traditions of the Israelite people, the ancient Israelite peoples, apart from those who did indeed worship the golden calf.
在古代近东地区，确实有许多传统是人们崇拜小牛、金牛犊或公牛。有时是用青铜制作的小牛。有时是在外表镀上金银合金的小牛。这个故事大概旨在将以色列人的传统与那些确实崇拜金牛犊的人区别开来。
Indeed, at one point in the ancient Near East and ancient Israel, there was a division between the Israelites, between the northerners and southerners. And the northerners went off and continued to worship the golden calf.
事实上，在古代近东和古代以色列的某个时期，以色列人之间曾发生过分裂，即北方人和南方人。北方人离开后，继续崇拜金牛犊。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: But the Bible that we have is actually the sacred text of the southerners, who hadn't gotten along so great with the northerners. In the southerner's version of the story, the calf was clearly offensive to God. But imagine, for a moment, the story told from the perspective of the northerners.
但我们拥有的《圣经》实际上是南方人的神圣文本，他们与北方人相处得并不融洽。在南方人的故事版本中，金牛犊显然冒犯了上帝。但试想一下，如果从北方人的视角来讲述这个故事会怎样。
(SUBJECT) PAULINE VIVIANO: At that period of time, the most normal thing would seem to be, well you worship a god who's in charge of fertility, and a god who's in charge of architecture and a god who's in charge of something else. So you have these multiple deities. From their perspective, you need all the help you can get. And worshipping a golden calf, that would be a fertility image, and fertility is what's going to be the most important thing settled in a land that is not very fertile.
在那个时代，最正常的事情似乎是：你崇拜一位掌管生育的神，一位掌管建筑的神，还有一位掌管其他事物的神。所以你有这些多神信仰。从他们的角度来看，你需要尽可能多的帮助。而崇拜金牛犊，那是一个生育象征，而生育是在一片并不肥沃的土地上最重要的事情。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: Part of what the story of the golden calf is about is how, by and large, we want to worship false idols. It is a deep impulse within us. Pauline Viviano says that there are hundreds of years of religious icons and paintings and saints and all sorts of things that of course are not intended as idolatry, but that come perhaps from the same impulse, to see a representation of God right here in the world. All the way till today.
关于金牛犊的故事，部分内容是关于我们如何在很大程度上想要崇拜虚假的偶像。这是我们内心深处的一种冲动。宝琳·维维亚诺说，几百年来宗教偶像、绘画、圣人像和各种事物，当然不是为了偶像崇拜，但可能源于同样的冲动，即想要在此时此地看到上帝的具象化。直到今天依然如此。
(SUBJECT) PAULINE VIVIANO: Now my family never did this, but I do know that some Italian families, they will bury a statue of St. Joseph upside down in the backyard if they want to sell their home. And the point is that if St. Joseph wants to get out of the ground, he will help in the selling of the home. It's that kind of use of an image that is actually being forbidden in the Old Testament. You're not supposed to control and manipulate the divine realm by the use of these images. But people need tangible things. We have medals. We have scapulars. We have all kinds of things because we are people enfleshed, and we like tangible signs. And many people have sold their house very quickly after burying the statue in the backyard.
我的家人从没这样做过，但我确实知道一些意大利家庭，如果他们想卖房，会把圣约瑟夫的雕像倒着埋在后院。重点是，如果圣约瑟夫想从土里出来，他就会帮助房子售出。这种对图像的使用，在《旧约》中实际上是被禁止的。你不应该通过使用这些图像来控制和操纵神圣领域。但人们需要有形的东西。我们有奖牌。我们有圣衣。我们有各种各样的东西，因为我们是血肉之躯，我们喜欢有形的标志。许多人在把雕像埋进后院后，房子很快就卖掉了。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: Well, today on our radio program. people worshipping the golden calf today, bowing before worldly things when they should not. Our program today in three acts. Act One, Bowing Before the Famous, the story about an accidental exchange of phone messages, one of the most famous singers in America and hundreds of people looking to be healed.
今天我们的广播节目将讨论：今天的人们崇拜金牛犊，在不该跪拜世俗事物时却俯首称臣。我们的节目分为三幕。第一幕，“向名流跪拜”，讲述了一次意外的电话留言交换，一位美国最著名的歌手和数百名寻求治愈的人。
Act Two, Thou Shalt Worship No Other Trousers Before Me. If you're enthralled to a pair of pants, is that necessarily such a bad thing? Is that so wrong?
第二幕，“除我之外，你不可崇拜其他裤子”。如果你被一条裤子迷住了，这一定是一件坏事吗？这样做真的错了吗？
Act Three, Don't Have a Golden Cow. A couple tries to get in on the San Francisco real estate boom, cash in, move up, with the sort of results you might expect even now, given the theme of today's program. Stay with us.
第三幕，“别养金牛”。一对夫妇试图赶上旧金山的房地产繁荣，想赚一笔钱并向上爬，但鉴于今天节目的主题，你大概能猜到结果。请继续收听。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: Act One, Bowing Before the Famous. One way to measure the faith, the pure, old-fashioned faith that we put in celebrities, is to examine what we ask of them. This next story is a vivid and rare glimpse of that, which comes to us only through a kind of accident and a series of phone messages. Ann Hepperman tells the story.
第一幕，向名流跪拜。衡量我们对名流所怀有的那种纯粹、老式信仰的一种方式，就是审视我们对他们有何要求。接下来的这个故事是一个生动且难得的窥探，这纯粹通过一系列电话留言的意外而产生。安·赫珀曼讲述了这个故事。
(HOST) ANN HEPPERMAN: I've known Josh since I was 16. We met at a wedding when my sister married his brother. Josh has been a Willie Nelson fan since he was seven. His mother loved the Redheaded Stranger album, and played it all the time. Josh remembers listening to it while he waxed the living room furniture for a dime. He's been to dozens of Willie Nelson concerts, and 20 years after he first heard his music, Josh decided to pay tribute to his idol in a rather unusual way.
我从16岁起就认识乔什了。我们在他哥哥和我姐姐的婚礼上认识的。乔什从七岁起就是威利·尼尔森的粉丝。他妈妈很喜欢《红发陌生人》这张专辑，一直反复听。乔什记得他用一角钱硬币一边打磨客厅家具，一边听这张专辑。他参加过几十场威利·尼尔森的演唱会，在第一次听到他的音乐20年后，乔什决定以一种相当不寻常的方式向他的偶像致敬。
I had a roommate that was moving out, and the phone was under his name. And so when we settled up the final phone bill and he moved away, we called the phone company to get the name changed and make sure the bill got to the right address. And the telephone service person asked me, "What name do you want your caller ID listed under?" And I thought to myself, hey, this is an opportunity to make that name say whatever I want. And so I said, "Let's have it say Willie Nelson." And she chuckled, and she said, "No really, what name do you want on your caller ID?" And I said, "Willie Nelson, that's one of my roomate's names." And so she did it. I never fathomed that it would create inbound calls.
当时我的室友要搬走，电话账户是用他的名字登记的。所以当我们要结清最后一笔电话费而他搬走后，我们打电话给电话公司更改账户名字，并确保账单寄到正确的地址。电话服务人员问我：“你希望你的来电显示名称列为什么？”我心里想，嘿，这是一个机会，可以让名字显示为任何我想要的。于是我说：“就写威利·尼尔森吧。”她轻笑了一声，说：“不，真的，你想要什么名字出现在来电显示上？”我说：“威利·尼尔森，那是我室友的名字之一。”于是她就这么做了。我从没想过这会招来这么多来电。
(SUBJECT) CALLER MELISSA: Oh my gosh, your answering machine voice doesn't sound a bit like your singing voice. This is Melissa. Boy, I can't believe I found you. Really, I love every one of your songs. I have every album, every album. I cannot believe it. Melissa, that's my name.
天哪，你的答录机声音听起来一点也不像你唱歌的声音。我是梅丽莎。天哪，我不敢相信我找到了你。我真的爱你的每一首歌。我有每一张专辑，每一张。我简直不敢相信。梅丽莎，那是我的名字。
I think that I wanted to do it not so people would think I was Willie Nelson, but so when I called out to other people, that on their caller ID it would show up and say, "Call from Willie Nelson." With the thought that I could somebody up and say, "Hey, I'm at Willie's house" and play a joke on my friends.
我想我这么做并不是为了让别人以为我是威利·尼尔森，而是当我去拨打别人电话时，他们的来电显示会显示“来自威利·尼尔森的呼叫”。我当时想我可以打给某人说：“嘿，我在威利家里”，以此开个玩笑。
(SUBJECT) CALLER MELISSA: I'm calling this number again until I get you. Willie, I love you. I love you, Willie. I'm calling back. I am. Since I was 16, you've been the only man. I can't believe I found your number. I cannot believe it. You're probably singing somewhere right now. You're probably touring. I can't believe it. I'm going to find out where you are. Oh my God. Are you with Roland and the boys? I bet you are. If you get a call in the middle of the night, answer it. It's me. I can't wait to talk to you. I'm going to call back again till I get you. Love you, talk to you soon. Bye.
我会一直拨打这个号码直到打通为止。威利，我爱你。我爱你，威利。我会打回来的。我是认真的。从我16岁起，你就是我唯一的男人。我不敢相信我找到了你的号码。我不敢相信。你现在可能正在某处唱歌。你可能在巡演。我不敢相信。我要查查你在哪里。天哪。你和罗兰他们在一起吗？我打赌一定是。如果你在半夜接到电话，接听它。是我。我迫不及待想和你谈谈。我会一直拨打直到打通。爱你，待会儿聊。再见。
(SUBJECT) CALLER 1: Hi, I'm not for sure, and I know this is just way on out there.
你好，我不确定，我知道这有点离谱。
(SUBJECT) CALLER 2: I was wondering if this was Willie Nelson. Willie Q. Nelson, country singer.
我想知道这是不是威利·尼尔森。威利·Q·尼尔森，乡村歌手。
(SUBJECT) CALLER 3: He's received some mail here, and it seems to be from an attorney.
他在这儿收到了一些信，看起来好像来自一位律师。
(SUBJECT) CALLER LINCOLN: My name is Lincoln Stamper, and I live in Oshkosh, Wisconsin.
我叫林肯·斯坦珀，住在威斯康星州的奥什科什。
(SUBJECT) CALLER 4: Hallendale, Florida.
佛罗里达州哈兰代尔。
(INTERVIEWER) IGGY SCAM: Saskatchewan, in Big Valley.
萨斯喀彻温省，大山谷。
(SUBJECT) CALLER 6: Grumman, Mississippi.
密西西比州格鲁曼。
(SUBJECT) CALLER 7: Formerly known as Montana.
以前叫蒙大拿。
(SUBJECT) CALLER 8: You rang me in 1991, and I want to return your call. I'm sorry I'm a little bit late.
你在1991年给我打过电话，我想回拨给你。抱歉我迟到了。
(SUBJECT) CALLER 9: If you're the singer, the blessed songwriter and singer, please call me.
如果你是那位歌手，那位受祝福的词曲作者兼歌手，请给我回电。
(SUBJECT) CALLER 8: If you pack your dinner bucket, you can walk up here and stay all night.
如果你带上你的晚餐桶，你可以走过来住上一整晚。
(SUBJECT) CALLER 10: You don't probably remember me but I'm from a long time back. OK, here's your number.
你大概不记得我了，但我很久以前就认识你。好了，这是你的号码。
(SUBJECT) CALLER 11: And if you would like to call my number collect--
如果你想拨打我的号码并要求对方付费……
(SUBJECT) CALLER 12: I was trying to get hold of Mr. Willie. Wasn't a big deal or anything. I just wanted to talk to him a few minutes if I could.
我正试图联系威利先生。没什么大事。我只是想和他谈谈，哪怕几分钟。
(SUBJECT) CALLER 13: I got a little song called "Deep Ellum Blues." And I'm going to blow the furniture off on it while you sing it. We're wasting time. Call me back Willie if you hear. I love you since 1976, "Blue Eyes Crying in the Rain."
我有一首小歌叫《深埃勒姆蓝调》。你唱歌的时候我会负责演奏乐器。威利，如果你听到了就回电给我，我们在浪费时间。从1976年起我就爱你，那首《蓝眼睛在雨中哭泣》。
(SUBJECT) CALLER 14: I'll talk to you later, bye.
待会儿聊，再见。
Hello, this is a collect call from--
你好，这是一通对方付费电话，来自……
(SUBJECT) CALLER JIM: Jim Howard.
吉姆·霍华德。
An inmate at the county jail. To accept charges, press 0. To refuse charges, press 1. To prevent calls from this facility, press 6.
县监狱的一名囚犯。如接受费用，请按0。如拒绝费用，请按1。如要阻止来自此设施的呼叫，请按6。
(HOST) ANN HEPPERMAN: Josh saved the messages because he didn't know what to do with them. He didn't know how to get them to Willie Nelson. He didn't have Willie Nelson's phone number. He tried to get it. He just coulnd't. Sometimes he was home when people called looking for the real Willie Nelson.
乔什留下了这些留言，因为他不知道该怎么处理。他不知道怎么把它们转交给威利·尼尔森。他没有威利·尼尔森的电话号码。他试过获取，但就是不行。有时人们打来电话寻找真正的威利·尼尔森时，他刚好在家。
At first, I just said, no, this isn't the Willie Nelson. And I would tell them, hey, maybe you should look on the back of your latest album and send a letter to the address on the album cover. But then, once in a while, I would take the call as if, yeah, you've reached the house of the Willie Nelson. I would say, he's on the road right now, but is there anything I can help you with? And so we would get into a dialogue, and they would say, I can't believe that this is really the house of Willie Nelson. And they would ask, who are you? And I would say, I'm just a friend hanging out at the house.
起初，我只是说，不，这不是威利·尼尔森。我会告诉他们，嘿，也许你应该看看你最新专辑的背面，把信寄到封面上的地址。但后来，偶尔我会接起电话，仿佛在说，“是的，你打到了威利·尼尔森家”。我会说，“他现在正在路上，但我有什么能帮你的吗？”于是我们就会开始对话，他们会说，“我不敢相信这真的是威利·尼尔森家”。他们会问，“你是谁？”我会说，“我只是住在家里做客的朋友。”
(HOST) ANN HEPPERMAN: Josh told me that over the three years he listed himself as Willie Nelson, he probably got some 500 calls. Peak times were around Willie Nelson's birthday, April 29, the Fourth of July, which is the time of Willie's annual picnic in Luckenbach, Texas, and Christmas. People called from nursing homes and mental hospitals. They called sober, and they called drunk. They called needing something they thought Willie Nelson could give them. A lot of people called needing something from Willie Nelson.
乔什告诉我，在他将自己列为威利·尼尔森的三年里，他可能接到了大约500个电话。高峰期在威利·尼尔森生日那天（4月29日）、国庆日（那是威利每年在得克萨斯州卢肯巴赫举行野餐的时间）和圣诞节。人们从疗养院和精神病院打来。他们有清醒的，也有醉酒的。他们打来电话，需要一些他们认为威利·尼尔森能给他们的东西。很多人打来电话，是需要威利·尼尔森提供什么。
(SUBJECT) CALLER 15: Hey, hi You don't know me but--
嘿，你好，你不认识我，但是……
(SUBJECT) CALLER 16: I'd like to talk to you a little bit about Thunder Child and if you have a couple of minutes to visit.
我想和你谈谈关于“雷霆之子”的事，如果你有几分钟时间闲聊的话。
(SUBJECT) CALLER 17: And I'm planning a music festival.
我正在计划一个音乐节。
(SUBJECT) CALLER 18: I could really use some help.
我真的很需要一些帮助。
(SUBJECT) CALLER 19: I need to find out about booking Willie for a big benefit.
我需要了解关于预订威利参加一场大型慈善演出。
(SUBJECT) CALLER 20: It's going to be at the Grenderry High School.
就在格伦德里高中。
(SUBJECT) CALLER 21: Can you help us?
你能帮帮我们吗？
(SUBJECT) CALLER 22: I have something amazing to show you.
我有些惊人的东西要给你看。
(SUBJECT) CALLER 23: See what you might charge us to come up here and put on a little show for us.
看看你要收多少钱才能过来给我们表演一场。
(SUBJECT) CALLER 25: I need to talk big time, baby.
我需要和你认真谈谈，宝贝。
(SUBJECT) CALLER 26: Please call. I keep trying.
请回电。我一直在尝试。
(SUBJECT) CALLER 27: I'm trying to book Willie Nelson as the headliner.
我正试图预订威利·尼尔森作为头牌明星。
(SUBJECT) CALLER 28: It's very important. I had some things that I wanted to talk to him about.
这非常重要。我有些事情想和他谈谈。
(SUBJECT) CALLER 29: And also, I'm a songwriter, and if you're looking for any new material.
还有，我是一名词曲作者，如果你正在寻找任何新素材。
(SUBJECT) CALLER 30: Please return the call. This is very, very important.
请回电。这非常、非常重要。
(HOST) ANN HEPPERMAN: A few people just wanted Willie Nelson to remember the time they'd met.
少数人只是想让威利·尼尔森记得他们曾经见面的时光。
(SUBJECT) CALLER 31: I'm not sure I have the right number, and I don't want to seem like a groupie. But if this is Willie, this is Nonie, N-O-N-I-E. And I worked at a farm with Bobby, and you came in and then we went to my apartment. And I cooked you eggs and bacon, you and some of your band members. And I just haven't had the guts to call you because I didn't want to seem like a nut, but I would really like to say Hi to you and Bobby. Thank you.
我不确定我是不是打对了号码，我不想看起来像个追星族。但如果这是威利，我是诺妮。我和鲍比在一家农场工作过，你进来了，然后我们去了我的公寓。我给你们煮了鸡蛋和培根，还有你的乐队成员。我一直没胆量打给你，因为我不想看起来像个疯子，但我真的很想向你和鲍比问好。谢谢。
(HOST) ANN HEPPERMAN: Then there were the calls that went beyond general requests.
接着是一些超出常规要求的电话。
(SUBJECT) CALLER 32: Hi, this is [UNINTELLIGIBLE]. I just want to talk to you. I just want to talk to you. I want to hear Georgia Goin' Down. I just want to hear those songs. Please call me back.
你好，我是……我只是想和你谈谈。我只是想和你谈谈。我想听《乔治亚之行》。我只是想听那些歌。请给我回电。
(SUBJECT) CALLER 33: My name is Karen, and I live in Abilene, Texas. And I have words for a song, and I don't want anything. I just want to hear it before I die. And I work. I have to work. I have written words for a song, and I know that people will listen if you sing it. I don't want anything because I'm dying. I just want you to sing, or fix it to where it can be sung.
我叫凯伦，住在得克萨斯州的阿比林。我有写好的歌词，我什么也不想要。我只是想在死前听听它。我还在工作。但我写了歌词，我知道如果你唱的话人们会听的。我什么也不要，因为我就要死了。我只是想让你唱，或者安排它能被唱出来。
I think that people connect him with kindness and gentleness, and they want to be soothed by him. And my feeling is that Willie probably gets more of these calls than your average celebrity because he is so kind and gentle and has that aura. But I don't know what to do when I hear a call like that. Those are the calls that make me glad that I am not myself a celebrity.
我想人们将他和善良与温柔联系在一起，他们想被他抚慰。我的感觉是，威利接到的这类电话可能比普通名流要多，因为他确实非常善良温和，拥有那种气场。但我不知道当我听到那样的电话时该怎么办。正是那些电话让我庆幸自己不是什么名流。
(HOST) ANN HEPPERMAN: On three occasions, Josh tried to forward important sounding messages to Willie. He'd go to a concert, work his way backstage, and give the information to a security person. He never knew if the messages got through.
乔什曾有三次试图将听起来很重要的信息转达给威利。他会去参加演唱会，设法挤进后台，把信息交给保安。他从未得知这些信息是否传达到位。
(SUBJECT) KENNY MORRIS: Willie, this is Kenny Morris. I live up in Gainseville, Texas. And I've been thinking a lot about you lately. And my mother is in the hospital and she has liver disease. My wife died three years ago of liver disease. And I've got some new ideas about how to help some people. And you probably have been feeling something pulling at you lately. So let's just talk about what this liver transplant program is about, and how we can administer to some of the patients that aren't as lucky as some of the other ones. And I feel something here. I feel like it's a new age. We need to figure out something to do. Thanks very much.
威利，我是肯尼·莫里斯。我住在得克萨斯州的盖恩斯维尔。我最近一直在想你。我母亲在医院，她得了肝病。我妻子三年前因肝病去世了。我有一些关于如何帮助人们的新想法。你最近可能也感觉到了某种力量的牵引。所以让我们谈谈这个肝移植项目是关于什么的，以及我们如何照顾那些不如其他人幸运的病人。我感觉到了，我感觉这是一个新时代。我们需要想办法做点什么。非常感谢。
(HOST) ANN HEPPERMAN: I was able to contact Kenny Morris, the man from this message. He was surprised and embarrassed to get the call. He hadn't told anyone about how he tried to reach Willie Nelson. When I told him Josh's phone listing was fake, he wasn't angry. He said it just seemed like a prank, although in his case, a rather cruel one. I asked him what he expected Willie Nelson to do when he received his call.
我联系上了肯尼·莫里斯，就是留言里的那个人。接到电话时他很惊讶也很尴尬。他没告诉任何人他是如何试图联系威利·尼尔森的。当我告诉他乔什的电话号码是假的，他并没有生气。他说这看起来只是个恶作剧，尽管在他看来，相当残忍。我问他收到电话时期待威利·尼尔森做什么。
(SUBJECT) KENNY MORRIS: I expected a call back. I checked my answering machine. It wasn't that I was going to be crushed if he didn't call back, but I wouldn't want-- that was my only choice. And I thought that it might hit some kind of a heart chord when he heard that message.
我期待回电。我查了答录机。并不是说如果他不回电我就会崩溃，但我不想——那是我的唯一选择。我以为当他听到那条留言时，可能会触动某种心弦。
I had this fantasy that he would come to the hospital and meet my mother. And that I knew that she didn't have long to live, and I thought that's probably the best thing I could give to her if Willie Nelson would have come in there and sang her a song. So it's jumping out in faith, trying to reach for something that's unattainable. But I still believe that you have to try.
我曾幻想他会来医院见我母亲。我知道她时日无多，我想如果威利·尼尔森能来给她唱首歌，那可能是我能给她的最好的东西。所以这是一种凭信心的跨越，试图去触碰某些不可及的东西。但我仍然相信，你必须尝试。
(HOST) ANN HEPPERMAN: Kenny says that looking back, he realizes just how crazy it was to think that Willie Nelson might come to his mother's bedside. But he says that back we called, that was a state of mind. He was grieving, and it made sense to him. Even though he didn't reach Willie Nelson, even though he never heard back, even though he actually had the wrong guy, he says the call might have done him some good.
肯尼说，回顾过去，他意识到认为威利·尼尔森会来他母亲床边是多么疯狂。但他说是那种心境让他打了电话。他在悲伤中，对他来说那样做是有意义的。即使他没能联系上威利·尼尔森，即使他没得到回复，即使他打错了人，他说这通电话可能对他有好处。
(SUBJECT) KENNY MORRIS: It helped me. I mean that probably took up a bad evening from me. I was probably in a pretty lousy state. I had just left the hospital. I was just realizing that my mother's fixing to die of the same thing that my wife just died of. And finding that telephone number and being able to leave that message, it probably helped me. It probably gave me a little time for my mind to cool off that night and probably allowed me to get a night's sleep. Yeah, I think it helped.
它帮助了我。意思是那可能帮我度过了一个糟糕的夜晚。我当时可能处于非常糟糕的状态。我刚离开医院。我刚刚意识到我的母亲就要死于和我妻子一样的疾病。能够找到那个电话号码并留下那条信息，可能帮到了我。它可能给了我一点时间让大脑冷静下来，可能让我那天晚上睡了个觉。是的，我认为它有帮助。
(HOST) ANN HEPPERMAN: I don't think Josh would ever admit this, but I think that he liked getting Willie Nelson's calls. But as Willie Nelson sings in the song, "My heroes have always been cowboys, who don't hold onto nothing too long."
我想乔什永远不会承认这一点，但我认为他喜欢接到这些打给威利·尼尔森的电话。正如威利·尼尔森在歌中所唱：“我的英雄一直是牛仔，他们不会长久执着于任何事物。”
I came home from work one day to find my answering machine light blinking like it frequently is. And hit play, and the first message that came out, immediately I recognized the voice.
有一天我下班回家，发现答录机的灯像往常一样闪烁。按下播放键，听到的第一条留言，我立刻认出了那个声音。
(SUBJECT) WILLIE NELSON: Hi, yeah, this is Willie Nelson. And I was just, out of curiosity, wondering what your real name is, if it really is Willie Nelson, since there's not many of us left. Maybe you could give me a call. Thanks a lot. Have a nice day.
嗨，是的，我是威利·尼尔森。出于好奇，我想知道你的真名是什么，如果真的叫威利·尼尔森的话，因为我们这种人已经不多了。也许你可以给我回个电。非常感谢。祝你愉快。
(HOST) ANN HEPPERMAN: In a way, this is a fan's best and worst case scenario, both at the same time. Your idol wants to meet you, but he's mad at you. The nicest guy in North America hates one person, and it's you. I caught up with Willie Nelson after a concert in Baltimore for a very rushed interview in his tour bus. He just wanted to make one thing clear.
从某种意义上说，这是一名粉丝最好也最糟的情况，同时发生。你的偶像想见你，但他很生气。北美最友善的人讨厌某个人，那个人就是你。我在巴尔的摩的一场演唱会后找到了威利·尼尔森，在他巡演巴士上进行了一次非常仓促的采访。他只想澄清一件事。
(SUBJECT) WILLIE NELSON: It's just none of this guy's business about what these people are telling me. Turn it around. How would you like for people to be picking up your messages? It's personal. It's just not anything I would like to see happen again.
这些人告诉我什么，完全不关这家伙的事。换位思考一下。如果别人在接听你的私人信息，你会怎么想？这是隐私。我不希望再看到这种事情发生。
(HOST) ANN HEPPERMAN: When the two men eventually spoke on the phone, Josh apologized. Willie was polite and invited Josh to meet him after a show in Austin. Josh met him backstage. Willie was gracious and forgiving. He asked Josh to stop. And so he did. But for Josh, things were different.
当这两个人最终在电话里交谈时，乔什道歉了。威利很有礼貌，并邀请乔什在奥斯汀的一场演出后与他见面。乔什在后台见到了他。威利表现得大度且宽容。他请乔什停止这种行为。于是他照做了。但对乔什来说，一切都不一样了。
I guess I preferred the relationship we had prior to that where it was more of fan and icon. I could still look up to him, and it was still an untouchable. I have tried to listen to the albums and not think about the phone number. And I've been somewhat successful. Certainly I got to meet him face to face. We got to talk and connect, but would I give that all up for a return to the fantasy? Maybe I would.
我想我更喜欢之前那种关系，那更像是粉丝与偶像。我仍然可以仰望他，他依然是不可触碰的。我试着听这些专辑而不去想那个电话号码。而且我取得了一些成功。我确实面对面见到了他。我们交流并建立了联系，但为了回到幻想中，我会放弃这一切吗？也许会。
(HOST) ANN HEPPERMAN: Unlike a lot of fans who called Josh's phone number, Josh never wanted anything from Willie Nelson. But by listing himself as Willie Nelson in the Austin phone book, he unwittingly put himself in a situation where he eventually was forced to see Willie Nelson as a man, not as a celebrity. And the fact is, Josh liked it better when he could just see Willie as a legend.
与许多打给乔什电话号码的粉丝不同，乔什从来没想从威利·尼尔森那里得到什么。但通过将自己列在奥斯汀电话簿中，他无意中陷入了一种不得不将威利·尼尔森视为一个普通人，而不是名人的境地。事实上，当他能仅仅将威利视为传说时，乔什更喜欢那样。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: Ann Hepperman lives in Flagstaff.
安·赫珀曼住在弗拉格斯塔夫。
[MUSIC - "HAND ON THE WHEEL" BY WILLIE NELSON]
[音乐 - 威利·尼尔森的《手在方向盘上》]
(HOST) IRA GLASS: Act Two, Thou Shalt Have No Other Pants Before Me. How much power can a pair of trousers have over us? Kate met Joel in 1990. They were both working in a psychiatric hospital in Belmont, Massachusetts. From the moment they met, Joel liked Kate, Kate liked Joel. But as things happen, it took awhile for each of them to figure this out, the mutual liking. and Kate spent a certain amount of time figuring out how to get in good with Joel.
第二幕，除我之外，你不可崇拜其他裤子。一条裤子对我们有多大的影响力？凯特在1990年认识了乔尔。他们当时都在马萨诸塞州贝尔蒙特的一家精神病院工作。从他们相遇的那一刻起，乔尔就喜欢凯特，凯特也喜欢乔尔。但事情往往如此，他们花了一段时间才弄明白这种相互的喜欢。凯特花了不少时间琢磨如何讨好乔尔。
I mean, the embarrassing thing is that basically I would check the schedule at the hospital each week, and look ahead to the seven days and find shifts when I was working with Joel. And then plan my outfits accordingly because I really wanted to look cute. And one of the things that I always relied on was that I had this pair of jeans that I thought looked really good on me. And I would purposely save the jeans, after laundry, to the day when I knew I was going to be working with Joel so that I would look real fine in front of Joel.
我的意思是，尴尬的是，我基本上每周都会查看医院的排班表，查找接下来的七天，找出我和乔尔一起轮班的时间。然后相应地计划我的穿着，因为我真的想看起来很可爱。我一直依赖的一样东西，就是有一条我自认为穿起来很好看的牛仔裤。洗完衣服后，我会刻意把这条牛仔裤留到我知道要和乔尔一起工作的那天穿，这样我在他面前看起来会很棒。
She did have this one pair of pants that I wasn't totally crazy about. The pants seemed not in fitting with the rest of her, and so it always threw me for a moment.
她确实有那条裤子，但我不太喜欢。裤子看起来和她的风格不搭，所以每次都让我一愣。
(INTERVIEWER) IRA GLASS: Describe the pants, please.
请描述一下那条裤子。
Well, they were acid washed.
嗯，那是酸洗的。
They were awesome. I loved them. They were acid-washed denim, speckly white, tapered at the bottom at the ankle. And a little bit, not balloonish but a little puffy.
它们太棒了。我很喜欢。那是酸洗牛仔布，带有斑驳的白色，裤脚在脚踝处收紧。有点，不是灯笼型，但有点蓬松。
And they ballooned out in the thighs in a sort of jaud Paris way. And the really crazy part was what happened up near the top. They had this fold over front area.
大腿处呈某种巴黎式的气球状隆起。真正疯狂的是顶部区域。它们有一个翻折的前部。
The feature of the pants that I thought made them really amazing is that they had at the top-- you have to try to picture this. They came up pretty high on your waist, like a good, gosh, four inches above your belly button. But at the very top of them in the front, they rolled over into this flap, this big flap. And they were very cool. There was a lot going on in these jeans.
裤子之所以让我觉得真的很棒，是因为顶部——你得试着想象一下。它们在腰部提得很高，大概有四英寸在肚脐之上。但在前部最顶端，它们折叠成一个翻盖，一个大翻盖。它们非常酷。这些牛仔裤里有很多名堂。
I don't want to pretend like I'm some incredible fashion maven. I'm not. But these were not a good-looking pair of pants.
我不想假装我是什么了不起的时尚达人。我不是。但这些裤子真的不好看。
(INTERVIEWER) IRA GLASS: What was the original context of these pants? I'm picturing a Boy George concert, maybe The Cure?
这裤子的原始背景是什么？我脑海中浮现出乔治男孩的演唱会，或者是“治疗”乐队？
Exactly, yeah, you got the timing right. I bought them at this store. I remember now, I bought them at a store in Boston. I bought them probably late '80s or '87, something like that, in this store that was very just '80s Boston clothes, which is just a certain look. I mean it's definitely got a little of the Bananarama thing going on, a little but of Boy George. But I'm still dragging them out at this point because I'm thinking they look so good on me, and I like them so much.
没错，你时间把握得很准。我是在波士顿的一家店买的。我现在想起来了，我是在80年代末，87年左右买的，那家店卖的完全就是典型的波士顿80年代服装，那是一种特定的风格。我的意思是，绝对带有一点香蕉女郎乐队的感觉，一点乔治男孩的味道。但我当时还是把它翻出来穿，因为我觉得我穿起来太好看了，我真的很喜欢它们。
So one of my strategies was I'd see if we were working evening shift together because an evening shift meant we were more likely, as a group of people, to go out for a beer after. And that would be a golden opportunity to wear the pants because you'd wear them, and then you're going to be out afterwards in a bar. And it's just like, I've got a whole evening of these pants at that point, and I know I'm going to be just golden.
所以我的一项策略是，看看我们是否一起上晚班，因为晚班意味着我们这群人更有可能在下班后一起去喝杯啤酒。那将是穿这条裤子的绝佳机会，因为你穿着它们，之后还要去酒吧。那时就觉得，整个晚上都有这条裤子撑场面，我知道我一定会成为全场的焦点。
(INTERVIEWER) IRA GLASS: Do you remember any key dates where you wore the pants?
你还记得穿这条裤子的关键日期吗？
A key date? The first night when it became apparent that Joel was interested in me was a night we had an evening shift. And then a bunch of us went to this bar, and the group started dwindling and dwindling and dwindling until it was left with just me  and Joel. And I was wearing the pants that night. And it was a very successful night because that was the night when he was making eyes at me, and I could tell this is going to go somewhere. He's going to ask me out.
关键日子？第一个晚上，当乔尔对我表现出兴趣时，就是我们上晚班的一晚。之后我们一帮人去了酒吧，人群渐渐散去，最后只剩下我和乔尔。那天晚上我穿着那条裤子。那是一个非常成功的夜晚，因为那一晚他一直向我投来目光，我能感觉到这将会有所发展。他会约我出去的。
(INTERVIEWER) IRA GLASS: Really, so the actual night that you turned the corner with your husband and the father of your child, you were wearing the pants?
真的吗？所以和你丈夫，也就是你孩子父亲感情出现转折的那天晚上，你穿着那条裤子？
Yes I was. That's right.
是的，我是穿着。没错。
(INTERVIEWER) IRA GLASS: That was the pivotal night on which your life turned from what it was to what it is.
那是你人生从过去转向现在，发生转折的关键夜晚。
That's right, that's right. Well said. Joel and I began dating, and I'm just very, very happy at this point because he's just a wonderful person. And I can't believe it's worked out, and we start dating.
没错，说得太好了。乔尔和我开始约会，那一刻我非常非常开心，因为他真的是一个很棒的人。我不敢相信一切就这样成了，我们开始约会。
So we're going along, and we're working together and dating. And it's reached-- I'd say we're at about four months at this point. So we've been dating for about four months, but it's at that point where relationships get where I think it's not super serious yet, but you know that this is going to keep going and this has a lot of potential. You're both clearly very into each other. So we're at that point, about four months, and Joel was actually over at my apartment.
所以我们继续一起工作、约会。我可以说当时大概过了四个月吧。所以我们约会了四个月，但那正是关系发展到我认为虽然还不是超级认真，但你知道这会持续下去并且很有潜力的时候。你们俩显然都非常投入。所以当时是四个月左右，乔尔正在我公寓里。
Kate's in her bedroom at her apartment, going through her clothes and figuring out which ones she should keep and which ones she should give to Salvation Army.
凯特在卧室里翻看她的衣服，盘算哪些要留着，哪些要捐给救世军。
And I opened up my drawer where I keep my pants and lifted the denim, the stonewashed pants out of the drawer, not at all because I was considering sending them to Salvation Army, but only because I had to move them to find the pants on the bottom of the drawer that of course I might send to Salvation Army. And as I pulled the pants out the drawer, Joel, sitting on the bed, sat there a minute and cleared his throat and said--
我打开放裤子的抽屉，把那条石洗牛仔裤拿了出来，完全不是因为考虑要捐给救世军，只是因为我得移开它，好拿到抽屉底下的裤子。正当我把裤子从抽屉里拿出来时，坐在床上的乔尔停了一会儿，清了清嗓子说——
"You sure you want to keep those pants?" And she stops and looks at me and says, "Well, yeah. Of course, I mean I think I do, why? And so I say, "Well, you know, I just think those pants are maybe a little bit out of style now."
“你确定你想留着那条裤子吗？”她停下看我，说：“嗯，是的。当然，我是说我想留，为什么？”于是我说：“嗯，你知道，我只是觉得那条裤子现在可能有点过时了。”
He said, "Well, do you think maybe they're just not in so much style anymore?"
他说：“嗯，你觉得会不会是它们已经不再流行了？”
And as the words are coming out, I see Kate's face flushing, becoming pinker and then red.
随着他这话出口，我看着凯特的脸开始泛红，变得越来越红。
And I was like, what?
当时我整个人都蒙了。
She's holding them in her hand, and looking at them, and looking at me, and looking back down at them. And I realize these aren't just another pair of pants. These were the special pants. And then i mean it's a very uncomfortable situation for me because a, again, I'm not a particularly fashionable guy myself so I probably don't have any right saying this to anybody. But then b, this is the woman who I've really fallen in love with. And this is one of the first moments when I've had to say to her, there's something about you, or something connected to you that I don't like.
她手里拿着裤子，看着它们，又看着我，然后又低头看它们。我意识到这不仅仅是另一条裤子。这是特殊的裤子。这对我来说是个非常不舒服的境地，因为第一，我本人也不是什么特别时髦的人，所以我可能没资格对任何人评头论足。但第二，这是我真正爱上的女人。这是我第一次不得不对她说，你身上有些东西，或者与你相关的东西，我不喜欢。
I couldn't believe it that these pants that I'd been purposely wearing in front of him for so many times and I thought had done such a good job for me-- and he was now saying I should put them in a bag and put them on the curb, basically.
我无法相信，这条我故意在他面前穿了那么多次，还以为帮了我那么大忙的裤子——现在他竟然说我应该把它装进袋子里扔到路边。
(INTERVIEWER) IRA GLASS: You thought that the pants had actually done a job on him. You thought the pants were part of your arsenal and part of your power over him.
你以为这条裤子真的对他起了作用。你以为这条裤子是你武器库的一部分，是你对他施加影响力的一部分。
I knew that they were part of what made me look foxy. And there he was basically-- four months into it where it had worked, we were together, and he was saying the pants are awful.
我知道它们让我看起来很有魅力。四个月过去了，它发挥了作用，我们在一起了，而他却说这条裤子很难看。
(INTERVIEWER) IRA GLASS: You know we're doing our show this week on the idea of the golden calf, the story of the golden calf from the Bible. And I feel like that story raises this question of, is the act of worshiping something, does that have value in and of itself even if you're worshipping the wrong thing?
你知道我们这周的节目是在探讨金牛犊的理念，《圣经》中关于金牛犊的故事。我觉得那个故事引发了一个问题，那就是崇拜某种事物这一行为，即使你崇拜的是错误的对象，它本身是否有价值？
Right, well, I think when I talk about it with you, it makes me think yes, because by worshipping the pants, they gave me confidence, which gave me, I think, some degree maybe of attractiveness to this person who ultimately I was trying to attract. Because clearly when I was walking around in those pants, I feeling pretty confident. I thought I looked great.
是的，嗯，当你和我谈到这个时，我想是的，因为通过崇拜这条裤子，它们给了我自信，我认为这给了我一定程度的吸引力，去吸引我最终想要吸引的人。因为很明显，当我穿着那条裤子走动时，我觉得相当自信。我觉得我看起来很棒。
(INTERVIEWER) IRA GLASS: And you felt that way because of the pants?
你觉得那种感觉是因为裤子带来的？
(SUBJECT) KATE: At times, yeah. Haven't you ever worn something and just thought, I look good right now?
有时，是的。难道你没穿过什么让你觉得“我现在看起来真不错”的衣服吗？
(INTERVIEWER) IRA GLASS: Do you think you could have gotten Joel without the pants?
你觉得如果没有这条裤子，你还能追到乔尔吗？
Wow, gosh. I hate to even have to think about it Ira. I don't know.
哇，天哪。艾拉，我甚至不想去想这个问题。我不知道。
(INTERVIEWER) IRA GLASS: You think the pants were that big of a factor?
你觉得裤子是那么重要的因素吗？
I don't know. I don't know. I mean it's been 11 years, but maybe those pants had something to do with it. I'd have to ask him. I'd have to ask him.
我不知道。我不知道。意思是已经过去11年了，但也许那条裤子确实有关系。我得去问问他。我得问问他。
I would have fallen for her if she were showing up in Garanimals everyday, say, or leisure suits or something. I mean as anybody knows who's ever fallen in love, you idolize the person you're falling in love with. And in those early days particularly, they feel perfect to you. And then you start asking yourself all sorts of questions. All sorts of insecurities come up. Why would this perfect person necessarily fall for me and accept me and want to be with me? But then when you discover a chink in that person's perfection, when you find a flaw, in this case Kate had bad taste at least in this one pair of pants, then it somehow makes you feel a little bit more comfortable. You feel like, maybe I do have a chance here because God, those pants had a chance with her.
即使她每天穿着廉价童装、休闲套装什么的，我也会爱上她。正如任何坠入爱河的人都知道的那样，你会偶像化你爱上的那个人。特别是在最初的日子里，他们对你来说是完美的。然后你开始问自己各种各样的问题。各种不安全感都出现了。为什么这个完美的人会爱上我，接受我，想和我在一起？但当你发现那个人的完美中有裂痕，当你发现瑕疵时，在这种情况下是凯特的糟糕品味，至少在这条裤子上是这样，这反而会让你感到更舒服一些。你会觉得，也许我还有机会，因为天哪，连那条裤子都有机会在她身上。
(INTERVIEWER) IRA GLASS: Let me read to you from the book of Exodus. Moses' reaction when he sees the calf, and the dancing actually. There's the calf and there's dancing. He gets rid of the new ten commandments, the brand new, freshly written ten commandments, breaks them at the foot of the mountain. And then in verse 32 of Exodus, says "And he took the calf that they had made and burnt it with fire and ground into powder and scattered it upon the water, and made the people of Israel drink it."
让我给你读一段《出埃及记》。摩西看到金牛犊和跳舞时的反应。有金牛犊，还有跳舞。他丢掉了新十诫，那些刚写好的十诫，在山脚下摔碎了。在《出埃及记》第32章中说：“他将他们所铸的牛犊，用火焚烧，磨得粉碎，撒在水面上，叫以色列人喝。”
If I have to think of that happening to those jeans, I'm going to be really depressed. They didn't deserve that. And I really wouldn't want to drink them. And of course, you know what I did, right?
如果我想到那种事发生在我的牛仔裤上，我会非常沮丧。它们不该受到那样的待遇。我真的不想喝下它们。当然，你知道我后来做了什么，对吧？
(HOST) IRA GLASS: What?
什么？
I threw them away. I gave them to the Salvation Army.
我把它们扔掉了。我捐给了救世军。
(INTERVIEWER) IRA GLASS: Did you regret it?
你后悔了吗？
I kind of did because I thought, I shouldn't have done that. I shouldn't have-- if we had been going out for a year and he said it, I probably wouldn't have done it. It was that four-month thing when you're still probably going to do the thing to please the person.
有点后悔，因为我想，我不该那样做。我不该——如果那时候我们交往了一年，他说这话，我可能不会那样做。那时候才四个月，你可能还会做些讨好对方的事情。
(INTERVIEWER) IRA GLASS: Whereas a year, you just are like, you're on your own here.
而一年后，你就像是，你随你的便吧。
(SUBJECT) KATE: It's like, ah, I'll still wear these pants. I would probably still be wearing them today.
就像是，啊，我还是会穿这条裤子。我现在可能还在穿着它们。
(INTERVIEWER) IRA GLASS: How lucky for him that he got you during that brief window.
他真幸运，在你那个短暂的窗口期遇见了你。
(SUBJECT) KATE: He was in the window. He didn't even know it.
他在那个窗口期内。他甚至不知道。
(INTERVIEWER) IRA GLASS: When you would actually do what he wanted.
就是你还会照他意愿做事的那个时候。
Exactly, exactly. I'd be sitting in them right now.
没错，没错。我现在还坐在裤子里呢。
(INTERVIEWER) IRA GLASS: You miss the jeans.
你怀念那些牛仔裤了。
You're darn right I do. Those were a great pair of jeans, and they're gone. 1990, I threw them away. Someone maybe has them, though. I recycled them to the Salvation Army so hopefully-- you know what I hope? That they brought some power to somebody else.
你敢肯定我怀念。那是一条好牛仔裤，但它们没了。1990年，我扔掉了它们。不过可能有人正穿着它们。我把它们回收给救世军了，所以希望能——你知道我希望什么吗？希望它们能给别人带来一些力量。
(INTERVIEWER) IRA GLASS: I don't know. I'm just trying to picture who would have bought them from the Salvation Army.
我不知道。我只是在想象谁会从救世军那里买走它们。
(SUBJECT) KATE: Somebody might have picked them up.
也许有人把它捡走了。
(INTERVIEWER) IRA GLASS: Like maybe some local theater company was doing an '80s version of Godspell.
就像也许有当地剧团在排演80年代版的《福音》。
They're doing The Breakfast Club at a dinner theater, and someone needed to wear them for the Ally Sheedy role. Look, all I'm saying is, if I still had them, you might still see me walking around in them today. They're going to come back, by the way.
他们在餐剧院排演《早餐俱乐部》，有人需要穿它们来扮演艾莉·希蒂的角色。听着，我想说的是，如果我现在还有它们，你可能今天还能看到我穿着它走来走去。顺便说一句，它们会回来的。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: Kate and Joel live in New York City with their now 12-week-old daughter, who they named Adeline after some debate.
凯特和乔尔住在纽约市，带着他们现在12周大的女儿，她在一番争论后被取名为阿德琳。
Can you imagine the conversations with Joel when we were picking names? Think of it, the taste issues.
你能想象我和乔尔取名字时的对话吗？想想看，品味上的分歧。
(INTERVIEWER) IRA GLASS: Were there other strong contenders or was Adeline a sweep?
还有其他强有力的竞争者吗，还是阿德琳胜出了？
Yeah, there was one I wanted that he didn't want. He thought it was tacky.
是的，有一个我想用但他不想。他觉得太俗气了。
(INTERVIEWER) IRA GLASS: Let's hear it.
让我们听听看。
Now I'm embarrassed, but I like the name Tatum. I'm stuck in the '80s movies. Is that an '80s thing?
现在我很尴尬，但我喜欢塔图姆这个名字。我陷在80年代的电影里。那是80年代的东西吗？
(INTERVIEWER) IRA GLASS: I would say that.
我会那么说。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: Coming up, the eternal question, money versus pee, which is more powerful? In a minute. I know all of our three year old listeners are going to stay around for that-- from Public Radio International-- when our program continues.
接下来，永恒的问题，金钱与撒尿，哪个更有力量？一会儿见。我知道我们所有的三岁听众都会留下来听这个——来自国际公共广播电台——当节目继续时。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program of course we bring you some theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, The Golden Calf, stories of people worshipping false gods, and whether that is always such a bad thing. We have arrived at Act Three of our program. Act Three, Don't Have a Golden Calf. What show about worshiping false gods could be complete without a story about money, or real estate, or hipness? Fortunately for us, this next story is about all three. Iggy Scam tells the tale.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周我们都会为你带来一个主题，为你呈现各种关于该主题的故事。今天的节目是“金牛犊”，讲述人们崇拜虚假神灵的故事，以及这是否总是坏事。我们已经进入了节目的第三幕。第三幕，“别养金牛”。如果一个关于崇拜虚假神灵的节目没有讲述金钱、房地产或时尚的故事，那该是不完整的。幸运的是，接下来的故事涵盖了这三者。伊基·斯卡姆讲述了这个故事。
(HOST) IGGY SCAM: When I first moved to the city, The Chronicle had run a story about the donut shop in the corner, the one with the huge sign that proudly proclaimed, "Open 25 Hours." The story in the paper called the corner where the donut shop was the epicenter of crime, and they meant for all of San Francisco. It was a staggering idea. I would sit in the donut shop and try to imagine crime, disturbance, discontent radiating outward across the entire city from that very spot 25 hours a day. Years later, I moved into my friend Jimmy's house on the alley behind the donut shop and got to sit back and watch it all.
我刚搬到这座城市时，《纪事报》报道过街角那家甜甜圈店，那家招牌很大、自豪地宣称“24小时营业（外加1小时）”的店。报纸称甜甜圈店所在的角落为犯罪中心，而且指的是整个旧金山。这是一个令人震惊的想法。我会坐在甜甜圈店里，试着想象犯罪、骚乱、不满从那个点辐射到整个城市，每天25小时。几年后，我搬进了朋友吉米家在甜甜圈店后面的胡同里，有幸坐下来观赏这一切。
On San Carlos Street, there was a daily sweet sad procession, a never ending back and forth that we could watch from our steps. There was the sound of man fruit bar carts up the alley, clanging their bells. And there was that tense, menacing no sound of cops cruising slowly the wrong way down the alley. The girl down the street that I had a crush on would walk, short sleeves in the Mission sun, smiling sweetly on her way to morning coffee at 1:00 PM. And Tony the drug dealer would walk the other way looking exhausted, sagging against a palm tree with gang tags carved into its weathered trunk.
在圣卡洛斯街，每天都有令人伤感的甜蜜游行，那种我们能在台阶上观察到的无休止的往返。胡同里有卖水果车的铃铛声。还有那种警察缓慢地逆向巡逻胡同的紧张、威胁般的静默。那个我暗恋的住在这条街上的女孩，会在下午1点微笑着，穿着短袖在使命区阳光下走向早间咖啡。而毒贩托尼会朝另一个方向走去，看起来疲惫不堪，靠在刻有帮派标记的棕榈树上。
My favorite time on San Carlos was 6:00 AM, just before the street woke up. Staring down the alley past the tired old Victorians and shoes dangling from telephone wires, I could imagine 10, 20, 100 of 6:00 AM's all exactly like this one, yawning and stretching into the past. It was a working class street, a ghetto alley, a place with problems that money wouldn't solve, but for now, asleep and dreaming.
我在圣卡洛斯最喜欢的时刻是凌晨6点，就在街道苏醒前。凝视着那条胡同，越过疲惫的老式维多利亚建筑和挂在电话线上的鞋子，我能想象出10个、20个、100个凌晨6点都一模一样，打着哈欠，延伸向过去。那是一个工人阶级的街道，贫民窟胡同，一个金钱无法解决问题的地方，但暂时处于沉睡和梦想中。
But the Mission was changing. Streets that had been called down and out were now called green, and the Mission's turd and graffiti motif is now fashionable. Termite-ridden, drafty old Victorians were bought at exorbitant prices, not to live in but to immediately resell like internet stocks. Everyone in San Francisco had a dream that somehow hinged on real estate. The stock market was pumping so much easy cash into the neighborhood, the good times were so good, that the dream even had a name, Cleaning Up the Mission.
但使命区正在改变。曾经被称为没落的街道现在被称为“绿色”，使命区的粪便和涂鸦成了时尚。长满白蚁、通风的老式维多利亚建筑以高昂的价格被买走，不是为了居住，而是为了像网络股一样立即转手。旧金山的每个人都有一个围绕房地产的梦想。股市向这个社区注入了如此多的流动资金，好时光如此美好，以至于这个梦想甚至有个名字：清理使命区。
Developers and slamming histories congratulated themselves, believing that the ordinary greed was actually a moral force, a rising tide to lift all boats. Our landlord up on the hill had bought into that dream too. Our landlord, who I'll call Maurice, was a dour-looking, henpecked little guy, a self-employed electrician who happened to own a couple houses. When I think of Maurice, I always think of him with his sad, black mustache and his tools, standing in the driveway as my roommate Jimmy came home from the flea market with his huge, green, grafitti-covered van.
开发商和历史抨击者们自我祝贺，认为这种普通的贪婪实际上是一种道德力量，是一种抬升所有船只的上涨潮。山上的房东也买了那个梦想。我们的房东，我就叫他莫里斯吧，是个看起来阴郁、怕老婆的小个子，一个刚好拥有几套房产的自雇电工。想起莫里斯，我就想到他留着悲伤的黑色胡子，手里拿着工具，站在车道上，看着室友吉米开着那辆布满绿色涂鸦的巨型面包车从跳蚤市场回来。
Maurice always seem to be thinking, how did this happen to me? He had bought our house eight years before and inherited Jimmy as his tenant. San Francisco's rent control laws are a stronger "'til death do us part" legal bind than marriage. And by law, Jimmy and Maurice would go to their graves with Jim still paying a sweet 1988 rent.
莫里斯总是似乎在想，这是怎么发生在我身上的？他在八年前买下了我们的房子，并继承了吉米作为房客。旧金山的租金管制法是一项比婚姻更牢不可破的法律约束。根据法律，吉米和莫里斯将带着吉姆支付的1988年租金水准直到死亡。
In the 12 years Jim had lived in San Carlos, he'd become as much a part of the street as the street sign itself. Everybody knew Jimmy. Even the gang kids dressed in blue shook their heads and laughed when the green van drove by. Jim was a self-employed scavenger who sold trash at flea markets, gave away more of it to anyone who asked. Homeless guys came by for clothes and blankets. Jim's friends came by looking for baseball gloves, or Super 8 projectors, or a PA for a protest at Civic Center, and he usually hooked everybody up.
吉姆住在圣卡洛斯的那12年里，他已经成为了这条街的一部分，就像街道标志一样。每个人都认识吉米。即使是穿着蓝色衣服的帮派小孩，在吉米的绿面包车经过时也会笑着摇头。吉姆是个自雇的拾荒者，在跳蚤市场卖垃圾，把更多东西免费送给任何有需要的人。无家可归的人来找衣服和毯子。吉米的朋友们来找棒球手套、超8投影仪或者去市政中心抗议用的扩音设备，他通常都会满足大家。
He was also a long-time neighborhood bartender and had a band. Just about everybody in the Mission had either bought a beer from Jimmy or played drums in his band.
他还是一名长期的社区调酒师，并有个乐队。使命区的几乎每个人要么从吉米那买过啤酒，要么在他的乐队里打过鼓。
Even though the Mission district real estate goldmine was becoming national news, Maurice never seemed ambitious enough to try to evict Jimmy and cash in. But he was married to Claire, a sour, always sneering woman with upwardly mobile aspirations of her own. Claire hated Jimmy. It was easy to imagine her up there on the hill working on Maurice, telling him if he was any kind of a real man, he'd get rid of that wing-nut trash salesman tenet of his, and they could sell the house and be rich. Or maybe she wanted to evict us and move into our house in the trendy, up and coming Mission that now had valet parking. We knew that Maurice's first wife had left him several years ago for another woman. Maybe Maurice thought that if he got left behind in the get rich quick housing market that Claire would leave him too.
尽管使命区的房地产金矿成了全国新闻，但莫里斯似乎从未有野心想尝试驱逐吉米并从中套现。但他娶了克莱尔，一个尖酸刻薄、总是向上攀登的女人。克莱尔讨厌吉米。不难想象她在山上做莫里斯的思想工作，告诉他如果他是个真正的男人，就应该除掉那个疯子垃圾推销员房客，他们就能卖掉房子变富。或者也许她想驱逐我们，搬进我们现在拥有的、有代客泊车的潮流街区使命区。我们知道莫里斯的第一任妻子几年前为了另一个女人离开了他。也许莫里斯觉得如果他在快速致富的住房市场中掉队，克莱尔也会离开他。
Whatever he thought, our house was now something else to him, a symbol of some brighter, well-heeled future. It was a chance, a chance for a henpecked electrician to finally hit it big, to be where the action was, to not be a small-time landlord anymore. And all they would have to do would be to get rid of us.
无论他怎么想，我们的房子对他来说现在是别的东西，是一个光明的、富裕未来的象征。这是一个机会，一个怕老婆的电工最终能大赚一笔、成为弄潮儿、不再做一个小房东的机会。而他们所要做的只是除掉我们。
We always paid our rent on time and had no problems with Maurice. It would be nearly impossible for him to legally evict us. So Maurice hired a notoriously ruthless and shark-like eviction trial lawyer, a man so stereotypically vile that when tenants' rights protesters staged demonstrations on his lawn, he would come out and greet them, waving and yelling smile as he videotaped them in action. Maurice's hotshot lawyer had never lost a case. He had a secret weapon, a little known law called the Ellis Act that allows landlords to evict their tenants if the landlord takes their property off the rental market forever.
我们一直按时交租，和莫里斯没有矛盾。他几乎不可能合法地驱逐我们。所以莫里斯聘请了一名以无情和鲨鱼般的驱逐律师著称的人，一个如此典型的卑劣分子，以至于当租户权利抗议者在他的草坪上示威时，他会走出来，挥手喊道“笑一个”，同时给他们录像。莫里斯这位热门律师从未输过官司。他有一件秘密武器，一项鲜为人知的法律叫《埃利斯法》，允许房东在将房产永久撤出租赁市场的情况下驱逐租客。
After they evict the tenants, the landlords can sell the property, move into it or turn it into a condo, but there is one catch. If the property is re-rented any time in the next 10 years, it has to be offered first at the old rent to the evicted tenants. This was not a big deal for Maurice's lawyer though because most people evicted under the Ellis Act didn't speak English and didn't know their rights. And the rest would move away and not fight it.
在驱逐租户后，房东可以出售房产、自住或改造成公寓，但有一个陷阱。如果在接下来的10年内该房产被重新出租，必须先按旧租金提供给被驱逐的租户。这对莫里斯的律师来说不是大事，因为大多数根据《埃利斯法》被驱逐的人不会说英语，不知道自己的权利。其余的人则会搬走而不去抗争。
The lawyer served eviction notices to us and our downstairs neighbors. Within a month, the neighbors had taken a settlement and left the city. But Jimmy decided to hire a lawyer and fight it in court. As long as the lawsuit went on, we would continue to live in the house and Maurice could not collect rent. Maurice and Claire were confident though. They sold their house on the hill and moved to the Mission. In fact, they moved in right downstairs.
律师向我们和楼下的邻居发出了驱逐通知。一个月内，邻居们拿了遣散费离开了这座城市。但吉米决定聘请律师，在法庭上进行斗争。只要诉讼继续，我们就会继续住在这所房子里，而莫里斯就收不到房租。不过莫里斯和克莱尔很有信心。他们卖掉了山上的房子，搬到了使命区。事实上，他们搬到了楼下。
The first month was awful. Jim said he could hear them through his walls giggling and having sex in the bathtub, something I did not want to have to imagine. They were clearly enjoying their new lifestyle in the resurgent Mission, playing the part of wealthy real estate movers and shakers. Claire had taken to smoking cigars, and she would stand on the porch and sneer with great satisfaction at us, arms folded, saying things like, "Have any luck finding a new place yet, Jim? Better start looking."
第一个月太糟糕了。吉姆说他能透过墙壁听到他们咯咯笑，在浴缸里做爱，这是我不愿想象的事。他们显然很享受在复兴后的使命区的新生活方式，扮演着富有房地产弄潮儿的角色。克莱尔开始抽雪茄，她会站在门廊上，双手抱胸，极度满足地冷笑着看我们，说一些诸如“吉姆，找到新住处了吗？最好开始找找看”之类的话。
They would have their one friend over and talk with him loudly in front of the house about how they would soon be rid of us. But I actually felt sorry for Maurice. The Mission was no place for this kind of hubris, and I think he knew it. The electrician was in over his head, and he was about to meet George.
他们会邀请他们的一个朋友过来，在房子前大声交谈，讨论他们很快就会摆脱我们。但我实际上同情莫里斯。使命区不是搞这种傲慢的地方，我想他知道。这个电工玩过火了，他即将遇到乔治。
George was the homeless guy who slept under our stairs. But to say George was just some homeless guy would be to say Shakespeare was just some writer. George had reinvented the role. With his trench coat and thick, greasy beard and wild mass of jet black hair, George was more of an ominous presence, a force, not so much a harbinger of doom, but a reminder that you were doomed. a feeling like a hangover that had always been part of San Carlos Street and always would be.
乔治是一个睡在我们楼梯下的流浪汉。但如果说乔治只是个流浪汉，就像说莎士比亚只是个作家。乔治重新定义了这个角色。穿着风衣，留着浓密的油腻胡子和一头狂野的喷黑头发，乔治更像是一个不祥的存在，一股力量，与其说是厄运的先兆，不如说是你已注定厄运的提醒。一种感觉就像宿醉，它一直是圣卡洛斯街的一部分，且将永远如此。
While everyone else in town was worried about eviction, George wandered the streets unconcerned because he was, in fact, in charge. He slept anywhere he wanted at any time of day. He would go to the pizza place on the corner, put his feet up on the sidewalk table and throw his head back, surveying his domain through always squinting eyes. He would not buy a thing. Instead, he had the power to assess taxes on passersby. If you had a six pack, George would always get a cold one off of you. If you gave him a cigarette, George would stroke his beard and yell, "Give me two."
当镇上每个人都在为驱逐担忧时，乔治在街上游荡，毫不在意，因为事实上，他是掌控者。他想在一天中任何时间睡在哪里就睡在哪里。他会去转角的披萨店，把脚翘在人行道的桌子上，仰着头，透过总是眯着的眼睛审视他的领地。他什么都不买。相反，他有权向路人征收“税”。如果你有一包啤酒，乔治总会从你那儿拿走一瓶冰的。如果你给他一支烟，乔治会抚摸胡须喊道：“给我两支。”
George also left massive turds in front of our garage door every morning. There was nothing you could really do about it, but he was pretty good about going in a bucket if you put one out for him. Since Maurice was new downstairs, we decided to see if he could figure this out. Maurice had lived on Bernal Hill, a nice neighborhood full of kindly older lesbians where everyone always seemed to be out walking their dogs. It was a pretty part of town with trees and views. Nothing there could have prepared him for George.
乔治还每天早上在我们的车库门前拉下巨大的粪便。你真没什么办法，但如果你放一个桶在那儿，他很乐意进去解决。既然莫里斯搬到了楼下，我们决定看看他能不能搞定。莫里斯曾住在伯纳尔高地，一个满是善良年长女同性恋者的好社区，每个人似乎都在遛狗。那是个有树木和景观的好地方。那里的东西没什么能让他准备好迎接乔治。
We would sit and drink beer on the steps and watch Maurice clean up after George. After a week or so of this, he installed one of those annoying security floodlights that turn on if anyone walks within, say, 100 yards if it. We were blinded anytime we walked up our steps at night. I found that if you just unscrewed the bulb a little bit, it wouldn't work. But one day George came by, and Jimmy asked him what he thought of the new light. George said, "Oh, I love those things. I can make sure I have all my things together before the light goes out and I go to sleep." After that, we quit unscrewing it.
我们会坐在台阶上喝酒，看着莫里斯清理乔治的遗留物。大概一周左右，他安装了那种恼人的安全探照灯，只要有人走进它100码范围内就会自动亮起。我们晚上走上台阶时总会被亮瞎眼。我发现只要把灯泡拧松一点，它就不会工作。但有一天乔治走过来，吉米问他觉得新灯怎么样。乔治说：“哦，我喜欢那些东西。在灯灭了我去睡觉前，我可以确保把我的东西都收拾好。”从那以后，我们就没再拧动它。
The case dragged on, and weeks with George stretched into months. Maurice and Claire's friend came over less and less, and then not at all. The bill from the hotshot attorney was mounting, and the flood of money into the neighborhood wasn't exactly cleaning up the Mission. No, if a rising tide was going to lift all boats in the Mission, that tide would not be money, but urine. The most visible nightly example of this so called economic revitalization was that the people pissing in our garden at night had on more expensive clothes. I'd come home to find giggling drunk girls in those huge shoes with their pants down peeing away in their driveway while their boyfriends drunkenly tried to pick all of Jim's flowers to give to them.
案件拖延下去，乔治的身影从几周变成了几个月。莫里斯和克莱尔的朋友来得越来越少，最后干脆不来了。顶级律师的账单不断增加，涌入社区的资金并没有真正“清理使命区”。不，如果上涨潮要抬升使命区的所有船只，那潮水将不是金钱，而是尿液。这种所谓的“经济复兴”最明显的每晚写照是，在深夜向我们花园撒尿的人穿的衣服更昂贵。我回家时会发现咯咯笑着的醉酒女孩穿着那种巨型鞋子，裤子褪到膝盖，在车道上撒尿，而她们的男友醉醺醺地试图摘下吉米所有的花送给她们。
I saw people mastering the art of pissing with one hand and talking on a cellphone with the other. The Latino working class bars in the Mission had all been systematically closed by the police because the patrons sold crack and got in fights with each other. They'd been replaced by hipster bars where the patrons all did coke and then went out to try to fight us. I'd see leather-coated, side burn-wearing guys scoring heroin at 16th and Mission and think, damn, it's like these people couldn't wait to move to the ghetto and lose their minds.
我看到人们精通一只手撒尿，另一只手打电话的艺术。使命区所有的拉丁裔工人阶级酒吧都被警察系统性地关闭了，因为顾客卖快克毒品且互相斗殴。它们被时髦酒吧取代，那里的顾客全嗑药，然后出来试图揍我们。我看着穿着皮衣、留着鬓角的家伙在第16街和使命区兜售海洛因，心想，该死，好像这些人等不及要搬到贫民窟发疯一样。
Maurice, apparently frustrated, next turned against the very thing that might make him rich, the property itself. Possibly inspired by the high-ceilinged, white-walled lofts that all the kids were into these days, Maurice started gutting the downstairs interior, ripping out the solid redwood cabinets and the counter tops that had been constructed over 100 years ago out of trees brought over on ships from New Zealand. The craftsmanship had stood up through three major earthquakes, but it would not survive a Mission real estate craze.
莫里斯显然很沮丧，转而针对可能让他发财的事物——房产本身。可能是受那些孩子们最近喜欢的挑高、白墙阁楼的启发，莫里斯开始彻底改造楼下内部，拆除了坚固的红木橱柜和Countertops，那些是一百多年前用新西兰运来的船只木材建造的。这种手艺经受住了三次大地震，却没能挺过使命区的房地产热潮。
The legal case had by this time dragged on so long that it was no longer clear what winning might mean. Maurice and Claire were always locked inside now, their security alarm evilly protecting them from the epicenter of crime of a mere 24 hours a day. A bunker-like paranoia emanated from the downstairs unit. One day, our phone wasn't working so we had a guy from the phone company come look at it. "Well, here's your problem," he yelled in disbelief as he lifted our grey box. Maurice and Claire were tapping our phone.
法律案件到这时已经拖了太久，以至于获胜意味着什么已不再清晰。莫里斯和克莱尔现在总是把自己锁在里面，他们的安全警报邪恶地保护着他们免受每天24小时的犯罪中心侵害。一种堡垒般的妄想症从楼下单位散发出来。有一天，我们的电话坏了，所以请了电话公司的人来看看。“嗯，这就是问题所在，”他抬起我们的灰盒子时，难以置信地喊道。莫里斯和克莱尔在窃听我们的电话。
Later, a small dispute over parking in the driveway ended with Claire punching Jimmy's girlfriend in the head. Soon after that, Claire apparently moved away, curiously being escorted by a younger man who carried her bags and opened the car door for her while she gazed longingly up at him. No more sex in the bathtub for Maurice. After that, we almost never saw Maurice, except when he came home from work and slammed his door.
后来，一场关于车道停车的小争执以克莱尔猛击吉米女友的头部结束。不久后，克莱尔显然搬走了，好奇的是，她被一个年轻男人护送着，男人替她提包并为她开车门，而她深情地望着他。莫里斯再也没有浴缸里的性爱了。在那之后，我们几乎没见过莫里斯，除了他下班回家时重重摔上门的声音。
And as for Jimmy, the block he had lived on for 12 years had changed considerably in a short time. Three Latino families down the block had been evicted under the Ellis Act, and now their former houses stood empty because they were more valuable that way. One was surrounded by rubble where the owner had tried to turn the Victorian into a loft but had run out of money.
至于吉米，他生活了12年的街区在短时间内发生了巨大的变化。街上三户拉丁裔家庭根据《埃利斯法》被驱逐，现在他们以前的房子空空如也，因为那样更有价值。其中一所周围满是瓦砾，因为房主试图将维多利亚建筑变成阁楼，但耗尽了资金。
Some of our friends had just given up and moved away, including the girl I had a crush on, who took her sleepy smile back to Louisiana. There were no weekend garage sales anymore at Jim's, and no one really came by to hang out on the steps. No one had anything good to talk about anyway, just more eviction news.
我们的一些朋友只是放弃了并搬走了，包括那个我暗恋的女孩，她带着困倦的微笑回到了路易斯安那。吉米那儿再也没有周末车库大甩卖了，也没人真正来台阶上闲逛。反正也没人有什么好聊的，只有更多驱逐的新闻。
After nearly a year, the judge ruled against Jimmy, and we had to move out. Maurice's winning deposition was a monumental, four-page list of over 70 complaints against us, a staggering document of an almost Kurtz-like collapse that Mission life had caused in Maurice. He accused us of having our house open at all hours day and night so that homeless people could just come in and wash their clothes. One innocent time when Claire found Jim and two male friends working on the car in the garage was described as an orgy.
近一年后，法官裁定吉米败诉，我们不得不搬走。莫里斯获胜的取证是一份宏大的、四页纸的名单，上面列出了70多条针对我们的投诉，这是一份关于使命区生活导致莫里斯近乎库尔兹式崩溃的惊人文件。他指责我们整天整夜敞开门，让流浪汉随便进来洗衣服。有一次克莱尔发现吉米和两个男性朋友在车库修车，那次无辜的事件被描述为一场纵欲派对。
In another complaint, Maurice accused us of, quote, "dragging heavy items across the floor all night in order to tape record the sounds." Well, it was easy to see why the judge had ruled against us. Maurice was just trying to do what he wished with his own property when he had suddenly found himself at the center of a sordid and vast avant-garde homosexual conspiracy, a Mission netherworld where the unclean and unhoused traded sex for laundry at twisted, 4:00 AM art shows. I said, "Man, I only wished we were that cool."
在另一份投诉中，莫里斯指责我们“整夜在地板上拖动重物，以便录下声音”。嗯，很容易看出法官为什么裁定我们败诉。莫里斯只是想用自己的财产做他想做的事，却突然发现自己处于一场肮脏而巨大的先锋派同性恋阴谋的中心，那是一个扭曲的使命区冥界，不洁和无家可归的人在凌晨4点的艺术秀中用性交换洗衣。我说：“老兄，我真希望我们有那么酷。”
The day we moved out was the only time that I ever actually saw Maurice's famous hotshot attorney. Everyone was there, waiting for the sheriff to come serve the final papers. Maurice came out to the top of his steps to wait. Claire finally pulled up, chauffeured by the younger man. And the lawyer pulled up in his SUV. He was the only one smiling. He strode confidently to the top of the stairs looking out into the alley, grinning as if he were about to address a crowded plaza full of supporters. After all, he'd still never lost a case, and he'd built a personal fortune on the one tried and true San Francisco idea that went all the way back to the first gold rush, the principle that the town was founded on. You don't get rich panning for gold. You get rich selling Levi's to all the fools who show up here every day to pan for gold.
我们搬走的那天，是我唯一一次真正见到莫里斯那名著名的顶级律师。每个人都在那儿，等着治安官来送达最后的文件。莫里斯来到台阶顶部等待。克莱尔终于开车赶到，由那名年轻男人担任司机。律师开着越野车也到了。只有他在微笑。他自信地大步走向楼梯顶部，凝视着胡同，咧嘴笑着，好像要向挤满支持者的广场发表演讲。毕竟，他从没输过官司，他凭借那个追溯到第一次淘金热的一条旧金山真理发了家。这个原则是：淘金淘不到钱，卖牛仔裤给那些每天来到这儿淘金的傻瓜才能致富。
The Sheriff finally came, papers in hand, and the lawyer led him up into our old house. But a moment later, they came out confused. They couldn't find Jimmy to serve him the papers. For the first time, the lawyer was irritated. He turned to us and growled, "Where the hell did he go?" Just then, Jimmy came out of the house next door and casually said, "Oh, I'll take those. Thanks."
治安官终于来了，手里拿着文件，律师带着他走进我们以前的房子。但片刻后，他们困惑地走出来。他们找不到吉米来送达文件。律师第一次感到恼火。他转身对着我们咆哮道：“他到底去哪了？”就在那时，吉米从隔壁房子里出来，随意地说道：“哦，我来收吧。谢谢。”
See, a couple days before, Jimmy had worked out a deal with the landlord next door. And now, Jimmy was moving into a room in the very next house. Jim said, "Hey Ig, can you give me a hand with these plants?" And Maurice and Claire watched in stunned disbelief as we dragged the planter boxes across the driveway to Jim's new home, a mere 10 feet away. They knew they wouldn't be able to rent the house to anyone but Jimmy for 10 years, and he would be right next door watching.
看，几天前，吉米和隔壁的房东达成了协议。现在，吉米搬进了隔壁的房间。吉米说：“嘿，伊吉，能帮我搬一下这些盆栽吗？”莫里斯和克莱尔震惊地看着我们把花盆拖过车道，搬进吉米的新家，仅仅10英尺远。他们知道在10年内，他们不能把房子租给除吉米以外的任何人，而他会一直在隔壁注视着他们。
Maurice stood at the top of the steps looking out across San Carlos Street, a street with problems that money couldn't fix. How could he have known what would happen next? That within a year, the real estate boom would bust, that the stock market would flounder, lofts would stand vacant all over town. How could he have known that in a few months, he would move out of the house that was his dream, and that the house would soon be covered in graffiti and trash, that the driveway would be full of homeless guys sleeping on couches, and that George would move to the top of the stairs? How could he know that the get rich quick scheme would fail, and that he would be unable to even sell the house because no buyer would want to rent it to Jimmy at a 1988 rent.
莫里斯站在台阶顶部，凝视着圣卡洛斯街，这条街的问题金钱无法解决。他怎么可能知道接下来会发生什么？一年内，房地产泡沫会破裂，股市会动荡，整个城市的阁楼会空置。他怎么可能知道，几个月内，他会搬出他梦想的房子，而那所房子很快会布满涂鸦和垃圾，车道会塞满睡在沙发上的流浪汉，乔治会搬到台阶顶部？他怎么可能知道快速致富计划会失败，他甚至无法卖掉房子，因为没有买家想按1988年的租金租给吉米。
I don't know, but from the look on his face that day at the top of the steps, I could tell that Maurice did know. He'd figured it out all at once as his high-paid lawyer got in his SUV and sped away, as the younger man opened the car door for Claire and they drove off too. The house was all his. Somewhere George was stirring for his morning rounds.
我不知道，但从他那天站在台阶顶部脸上的表情，我能看出莫里斯确实知道了。当他高薪聘请的律师开着越野车疾驰而去，当那个年轻男人替克莱尔打开车门，他们也开车离开时，他一下子全都明白了。房子全是他的了。某个地方，乔治正在为他的晨间巡逻而起身。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: Iggy Scam lives in San Francisco.
伊基·斯卡姆住在旧金山。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: Well, our program was produced today by Alex Blumberg and myself, with Wendy Dorr, Jonathan Goldstein, and Starlee Kine. Senior producer Julie Snyder, contributing editors Paul Tough, Jack Hit, Margie Rockland, Becca Carroll, Alix Spiegel, Nancy Updike, and consigliere Sarah Vowell. Elizabeth Meister runs our website. Production help from Todd Bachmann and Annie Baxter. This is Annie's last show with us, the end of her training. She has served at the altar of radio. Radio, the only true medium, and we encourage her to continue on that one true path. And we wish her the best.
我们的节目今天由亚历克斯·布伦伯格和我制作，温迪·多尔、乔纳森·戈德斯坦和斯塔莉·凯恩参与。高级制作人朱莉·斯奈德，特约编辑保罗·塔夫、杰克·希特、玛吉·罗克兰、贝卡·卡罗尔、阿利克斯·斯皮格尔、南希·厄普代克，以及顾问莎拉·沃威尔。伊丽莎白·迈斯特负责网站。托德·巴赫曼和安妮·巴克斯特协助制作。这是安妮随我们参与的最后一场节目，她结束了培训。她侍奉于广播的祭坛。广播，唯一真正的媒体，我们鼓励她在那条唯一正确的道路上继续前行。我们祝愿她一切顺利。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
To buy a cassette of this or any of our programs, call us here at WBEZ in Chicago, 312-832-3380. Or you can get cassettes from our website. You know where you can also listen to the shows for free, www.thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
购买本节目或我们任何节目的磁带，请致电我们在芝加哥的WBEZ电台，电话312-832-3380。或者你可以从我们的网站获取磁带。你知道你也可以在那里免费收听节目，www.thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台分发。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[赞助名单]
WBEZ management by Torey Malatia. Torey, who prefers to be known as--
WBEZ管理由托瑞·马拉蒂亚负责。托瑞，他更愿意被称为——
(HOST) IGGY SCAM: The center of a sordid and vast avant-garde homosexual conspiracy.
那场肮脏而巨大的先锋派同性恋阴谋的中心。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life .
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。